other members
are
leg
purpose of St here is consider
application for RW of
license one of the
LIC
purty
this
Council introduce
themselves the principal
licing you have any
Witnesses pleas the responsible
Authority receive the agenda
on any
Witnesses
received proced
item yes good
morning so this is a review of the
premised LIC application under section
51 of the licensing act 2003 for craft
cast in is RO ra the application is for
the following licensing objective which
is the prevention of public nuisance
which is namely the live
musication is for a review of premises
license and was submitted to the local
Authority by Mr burges on the 31st of
October
2023 and again as was stated relates to
crafty CS appendex a of the
documentation in the submission um is a
copy of the um application for the
review bit of background
informationis to which this application
relates is a micro Pub um situating on
the junction of Websters way and
Eastwood Road John Smith who is present
here has held the license with Russia
District Council on this current license
in
2022 and a copy of the license the
correct license has been submitted and
is reference number RDC 22
L and again has been part Sal as part of
the evidence
fund prior to that the V hold the
license um in 2019 under a different
license
number9 2015
L sorry La
a plac since um 2019 to
2022 however that license was then
surrendered when this new license was
then introduced the current license
benefits from what is known as the live
music Act and the live music
deregulation the live music act came
into force on the 1st of October 2022
and deregulates live music so as in the
report what is the live music
act the ACT allows the licensing
requirements for live and recording
music to take place where there is a
premises license or a club certificate
in place permitting on sells of alcohol
the premises are open for the sell of
alcohol for consumption on the premises
and live and recorded music can take
place between 8:00 a.m. and 11:00
p.m. if the music is Amplified live
music or recorded music such as DJs or
um discos for example the audience has
to consist of less than 500
people the license doesn't include any
sort of regulated entertainment around
live music between 8:00 a.m. and 11:
p.m. on the license as it benefits from
the live music Act and the reason why
there is no conditions that are
currently attached in relation to the
live or recorded music during that time
period but the ACT does say there are a
number of mechanisms to protect the
residance and these are upon a review of
a premises license the licensing
Authority can determine that existing
conditions on the premis license
relating to live or recorded music will
apply either between 8:00 a.m. and 11:
or if the premises license doesn't
presently authorize Live recorded music
the licensing Authority can determine
that live or recorded music at the
premises can no longer be provided
without permission on the premises
license thus requiring a variation of
the licence or via a tempor event notice
and can add new conditions to the
premises
obviously there are still other
legislation that is in place around the
Environmental Protection Act of 1990 and
this will continue to apply the live
music act does not allow license
premises to cause the noise
nuisance in relation to representations
as I've already said the copy of the um
the review application was circulated to
all the responsible Authorities on the
31st of October 2023 advertised on the
council's website and a copy of notice
was placed on the window of the rer
council offices at South Street in
accordance with the regulation the
application was for a full review and
advertised on the 31st of October 2023
inviting representations by the deadline
of the 28th of November 2023 blue
notices were placed on the outside of 33
Eastward road on the actual premises my
confirmed that we took PR gr of them in
to compliance in relation to responsible
authorities neither ethics police Rocher
District Council licensing team nor
rochia District council's environment
health Team have supported this review
no other representations were received
during the consultation
period under the legal implications when
determined the review of a premise
license the committee must have regards
to the promotion of the licensing
objectives these are prevention of crime
disorder Public Safety prevention of
public nuisance and protection of
children from
home in relation to notices all parties
involved have been served with the
relevant notices in accordance with
paragraph six and S of the licensing act
2003 hearing regulations of 2005 the
notices and documentation including the
explanation of the rights of persons to
attend the hearing and to be represented
and give evidence call witnesses the
consequences of not attending the proced
to be followed at the hearing and for
the applicant only a copy of all the
relevant representation
made paragraph 89 of the regulations
require that parties notify licensing
Authority no later than five working
days before the hearing of those matters
mentioned above and a pro for was sent
out to all those parties involved which
I have again got copies of those
conclusion
no and jump down to options um for the
committee paragraph 11 the following
options are available to the members
they can modify the conditions the
suction extent as members consider it
necessary for the promotion of the
licensing
objective manry conditions that must be
included to exclude from the scape of
the license any license for activities
to which the application this review
application relates uh to remove the
designated premises supervisor to
suspend the license for a periods not
exceeding three months to revoke for the
license or the last option is to leave
the license in its present
State under again the regulations
paragraph 11 to13 of the hearing
regulations um 2005 the committee can
adjourn the hearing to a specific date
and to arrange for the hearing to be
held on specific additional dates where
the members consider it to be necessary
for the consideration of any
representations or notices made by the
party that is the summary of the back
information
question
Prov um do we want to ask the residents
for their case first and then we
ask
down
follow
against
whenever you
do well just
did
and a
case not the volume coming up through
the floor but the stairwell need to
conduct the sound from
below through through the floors um and
just clearly
heated when it's happening
he's turn his own music up to drown it
really satisfactory I think he's also
noticed um some
drinkers taking their glasses or bottles
outside uh which is against the R so I
think Safeguard should be put in place
so that F Andes aren't taken
outside C out smoke um but yeah I
sympathize I know Mr Smith has put in
sound um suppressing measures so he's
done everything he can to mitigate the
actual transmitted but this be a
particular problem with it being
conducted up to stairwell and I I don't
think there's anything you can do about
that other than you know stop the music
impress the music
SCE
so I certainly don't want to
see
because I think it's a useful addition
to
the well established and used bar and
you know it's great for the people that
use it um certainly wouldn't want to see
it closed down but some limitation of of
the Music Volume would especially
unamplified
music main issue
here have we um have we got
any actual data have you got any
monitored noise
levels
to ask
whe
this could put
your okay uh I'm sure Mr
bird quite
[Music]
sincere
reasonable however um what
unreasonable matter
protection well we wish to have a sound
level suitable for our music and our
customers so just
about
Qui in this situation I think it's
necessary for a
disinterested decide on the level that
respects right a reasonable quality of
life while still allowing us to conduct
our
business I feel that this matter was
dealt with some time ago we had
complaints about the sound level from
another neighbor and we were required to
install a sound limit to a level agreed
by Rood environmental
health worked very closely with
environmental health while they
conducted thorough and professional
investigation after a number of visits
from them they agreed that the sound
level should be limited to 85
festivals to give this figure some
context it the same level required by
the legislation for all venues during
the co
pandemic this level was chosen so that
people did not have to speak loudly in
order be
heard give you some idea of the the
volume in the
bar we don't have rock bands or play
Heavy Metal mus bar on Friday evenings
we usually have a single musician with
an acoustic guitar occasionally we may
have a Duo all our artists play their
own instruments do not have singers that
use backing tracks all our singers
are almost always local talent on Sunday
afternoons we will usually have another
singer with a guitar Sunday evenings we
have an open mic session where local
artists free to show off their talent
these are not
karaoke the artists play their own
instruments or are accompanied by the
open White
Post feing crafty cast is the first step
on the ladder for many of the musicians
and a number of them have gone on to
paid
engagement I do take the point about the
SE he's a very wellknown
um musician who plays from
M some of the
mar and
yes it is the saxophone is quite loud
and we would be happy to stop that but
she brought down um some other
famous musicians to act the duo with him
um
and it would be sad if he couldn't play
there anymore but I do take the point
that that's phone is uncontrolled
because it doesn't go through our
sounding
to uh Mr burges lives on the second
floor he says that the sound travels up
the stairwells stairwell walls rather
than through the
floors the same stair wheel walls also
serve the Flats on the first floor so
the walls go up the stairwell past first
floor and then up to Mr burges say STW
world does not extend to the second
floor and we've had no complaint from
any of the flats in the first
floor I don't believe Mr burges has
offered any evidence to support his
application none of Mr Burg's neighbors
have made representation of support of
his
application and none of the relevant
authorities after having reviewed the
application of to support the
application I believe that the absence
of support from rutford environmental
health is particularly
significant environmental health have
work TIR tirelessly to determine a sound
level that works for all parties and I
feel that their judgment should be
respected I also that the application is
rejected and the LI is
not very do you have any
questions yes um so what measures have
you got
in your actual premises what sound
proof um we
soundproofed the um W to the
STW and uh we
have um found absorbing
uh tiles on the walls and ceilings
although this is more to do with the
accuse the accus SS got found
[Music]
reverberating um but
it it does
help the tiles are not there for um
sound pring but all is um
separately down multiple layers of down
deading materals
andity we've also taken some additional
method
um additional measures to ensure that
the bench pipes going up through the
building are insulated as well
the landlord the
Freeholder of the whole building
[Music]
anything
just something you did consultation with
installation company no um we engaged
some
um
uh found
Consultants um
who came down to do a survey did ask for
Access FL but Mr Burgess
wasn't
umate or be disturbed
but he he asked if it was NE if he had
to allow access he was um didn't
have all access
to you have any reports I I do but I
don't
[Music]
have provide
them sorry interrupt um it was a
acoustic engineer that came down to do
the assessment an independent assessment
of the noise um that was um brought in
for the initial S complaints and then
worked with environmental health to then
look at the measures that need to be put
in place and then they did a followup
survey again quite technical U with
specifics around the how the sound has
traveled um but obviously our envir
health Team have got a copy of those
reports that they were satisfied with
the measures that have been put in place
to address the the noise that on on
behalf ofal Health District Council that
was at the request of Russia District
Council environmental health Team um to
see the initial report and then to do a
followup report after measures have been
put there is no
way
corridors
from the street um but stairwell also
doesn't go
through verges
um separate
ilding the outs of the
building separate
yes no
connection have you had any complaints
from the
immediate no
two between you
and yeah yeah in in the summer do you
have Windows Doors Open um we never had
the doors open when loud
music
um and we normally have the front door
open until
7.m
when you close the door yes what
about
to
I would like to say
that there's a bit right very end we can
summarize and then you can say summarize
app is the duting for the air
conditioning does that go anywhere near
Mr
system yes it's Abed system um but uses
two heat
exchanges um sorry two
sets one
set is contained within the building and
then just the refrigerant is pumped to
the outside which goes to another
so there is no duct that go from inside
building to outside
building no no
ventilation no we we have a um heat
recovery
system um that
has vent going to the front of the
building but uh it's totally
silent when it's on
I guess when the Pub's empty and and
that's the maybe
hear you want to up and resp to comments
being said
else you want to say just the
me
resp back
sound
doesn't
you're get back up back up I lost my
two come up
see I take the
point U
about
the
um is something I was concerned about
because volume of it is quite loud
and because it's an accoustic instrument
it doesn't go through the sound system
and I can't control it so I'm quite
happy to have a
chat um without customer say thank you
but
please don't bring your
[Music]
tax it's prob he probably played there
about three
times did
you is
that you put more in place
[Music]
and I believe um
green
yes
L louder than the empi
music so that's not
General yes I would say no more than
three three or four times
over there is nothing other the moment
during the
meeting and we will consider
the thank you very we're going the other
room and we will wait um and I'll wait
for
um for to come back
in we
have
application Authority by m BG on the
31st of
october23 the
premises the application was unreason
under
the during the course of the hearing
licing of mut to the
application Mr B to explain that the
noise was loud and came through into the
stairwell had no other issues with the
bar it was just
volume heard from the respondent
regarding the business and
managing
sounding
and F heard that there been cooperation
of environmental health satisfied with
the steps that have been
undertaken further to this the committee
noted that the respond bit the STX
offing the volume and limit CL the CL
that this is one of the main caes think
that it did not go through the
amplify the sub committee make it clear
that they this application LIC objective
sub committee resol to leave the license
in it State making it decision subte own
license guidance and statement of policy
the statut guidance please know that any
license is always subject to
review anyone affected by this decision
invite to appeal the magistrates within
days much thank you than that conclud
the